my name is irises you know working a
double is on principle solutions
engineer so the math could besides
undergrad deaden studied cognitive
science and neural networks was called
back in the ancient times and University
of Toronto so in 2016 they WS we embark
on a mission to basically democratize AI
deep learning specifically so we're just
a small group of us and they're in the
early days the whole idea was which is
the core strategy of AWS AI of which I'm
a member of what's to make sure that
more and more engineers and scientists
of difference basically disciplines can
actually get engaged in deep learning
and develop things that they want to
develop we develop a range of products
for a range of open-source software we
got Apache MX MX now we made an Apache
project and incubating at the moment and
these are the very latest developments
we've done there are two things that I'm
going to go through very quickly and
magically within the 30 minute time that
we have so my mission is that you would
be expert in 15 minutes so you go out
and start using them or you curse me I
never again come to any of my talks so
the barrier to entry is actually quite
high when you try to do deep learning it
used to be worse I remember we do used
to do more math and programming and then
it's more programming than math but
despite having library is it's still
quite complicated because you have to
know so much in order to get something
working so what are the challenges the
challenges are you don't have enough
data or basically you don't have the
scientific expertise in your
organization you have a steep learning
curve with a whole new range of tools
like for instance millions of Java
developers have no access to Python they
have to learn the language they have to
learn all the libraries around it they
have red pandas they have to learn this
and that so and that's very complicated
for a lot of people and so and then
experience of optimizing what you do is
the other thing I'll give you an example
a I came across in
Tokio company that had one of these
basically a deep learning team who just
copied things from the tutorials and
then a start training their models could
never go beyond two GPUs and it would
take about two days to train their
models optimization of that took less
than two days and then the training went
down to under an hour on basically
running eight GPUs and utilizing 100%
and that sort of optimization is an
experience that you can't there is no
compression algorithm for it you just
have to go and through that over and
over and over again in order to know
what the key things are so how are we
addressing those so for instance one of
the most popular things that I can do is
the model zoos that give you the model
to make it easier while at the same time
activate transfer learning so you see
that this is from MX net when they say
pre-training equal true from modeling
model Zoo it actually loads the model
parameters and the weights for you and
then it can just change the final layer
of it and train it again on your own
data that means for the amounts of data
we have gathered we have done
pre-training of this model we actually
have models that are ready for inference
or you can actually train them further
so through transfer learning you don't
have to go through a whole lot of pain
of training your models then we have
developed a whole bunch of toolkits and
we're not stopping so 2018 we released
glue on CV which is a computer vision
toolkit with its own modeled zoo and
50-plus algorithm in it and the
utilities glue on NLP for natural
language processing and 300-plus am
bidding and language models and there
and then we published a book deep
learning to die basically done dive too
deep learning that is an interactive
notes book base books that you can
actually use and also gluon which is a
part of the talk that we are going
through today that includes basically
architecture search and enos basically
to diff to find the best architecture
for you so that it makes dark architect
internets work lots easier then how
about the learning curve of new tools
we used to have the envy array that
belonged to MX Ned we have changed that
now to deep numpy so your exact number
code just simply works and runs on
multiple GPUs parallel losses and that
sort of stuff and then we created for
two for four also in 2019 we released
glue on TS which is a time-series
toolkit that is just basically fully
adopts pandas whatever you do panda is
it just works in there too we just use
pandas directly under it so to make sure
that we are becoming more and more
compatible with the non pie ecosystem
something that didn't exist in early
days so how do we deal with the
optimization so also gluon gives us out
so ml is a full on how to basically auto
ml toolkit it's used for fast
prototyping automated high performance
optimization using multiple algorithms
including the Bayesian models and
reinforcement learning it basically uses
the state of the art to learning
techniques as I said like for instance
for NASA and eNOS and it provides you
with a massive set of configuration
options which is all supplied as default
if you're a newbie but if you want to go
and optimize it there are just tens and
tens of tens of promises that you can
actually use for more advanced users and
the distribution computation is
completely abstracted away you don't
have to deal with it it just happens
behind the scene you just say oh I want
it to be distributed I want to have
three GPUs and that's about all you need
to do everything else is done behind the
scene for you so we have removed that
complication of distributed programming
that used to be very much I know fun
probably so let's go to deep numpy
what's the motivation with the models
ooh is being developed more and learn
more in every framework so we are back
to the vast majority of the time being
spent on pre-processing of data so
pre-processing of data has become again
this like the majority activity that you
do so but then you want to run these
things on basically multiple GPUs
parallelize your processing
you have to so things like numpy
wouldn't be able to do that so everybody
started developing their own set of data
structure for it and what we developed
was the nd array under glue one under MX
net sorry and then what happened here
was it was not fully compatible through
not being fully compatible then you
would end up with some behavior you
didn't expect and you didn't probably
enjoy getting strange weird errors for
something that is supposed to be similar
to what you have been used to use so we
basically very recently released as a
part of a Apache 2.0 license MX nets
basically for a sorry initially we
basically created MX net nd when you see
here there are three three sets of code
in here if you look at it the one up
here is just a pure end the array coming
from MX net so what we do here we're
just simply trying to do a dots matrix
multiplication so you get basically and
the random normal you get a standard
distribution with the shape of a
thousand by a thousand and then you just
dots multiplied by itself and then you
get the time as you see the time is here
is basically 0.001 etc etc then you
could actually do that on a single GP
you could also do it on a multiple GPU
on a single GPU you repeat the exact
same code you see it gets faster so
that's very nice and the array of runs
and GPU and then you can do the same
thing on numpy that you see even when
you're using CPU there's a huge
difference the question is can we get
the familiarity of this and get the
performance that we get from these other
two code blocks so that's what we just
released recently and that is the same
thing as you this is the same old numpy
code as you see the non PI code runs on
top so rather than we had ND random norm
also we have numpy random normal and
then it's the gain that's a standard
Gaussian distribution and then your half
here get the time than your
multiplication next line what we do we
see
we import n P and NP X and we say NP x
set MP that is telling us even you know
when the type of numpy using underneath
is going to be now deep numpy that has
distribution capabilities that has a
whole bunch of jeep abilities and then
you can run the same thing so here I
have the exact same code that's I had
previously plus I have just added a
context street so everything we used to
have now you can identify a context for
it otherwise the code remains the same
so I'm telling here you context is
basically or GP it's the context here is
GPU and then I run the same thing I get
the GPU result here 0 0 0 8 or here I
have not identified the next line and
then you see the time is going back to
being numpy like so this is a standard
numpy and what we have in here is deep
numpy on cpu and what we have in here is
no that's an ND array sorry on CPU and
what we have in here basically is going
to be the deep numpy oh so i had done
one slide back sorry forgive me so now
that's the correct one we have the non
PI then we have the NP X we have the
deep numpy on CPU and deep numpy on GPU
so the comparison here as you see the
deep numpy on CPU still massively faster
than the normal non point you can make
it faster using GPU but your numpy code
is identical is actually in a non Piko
it hasn't changed at all through just
telling the framework you're using deep
numpy rather than non pi sorry for
skipping backward a page by accident it
looks very weird any questions so far
about deep numpy now you can use deep
numpy the way it is under pipe basically
torch users can use it m extend users
can use it you just simply are going to
use non pipe normal non poi and just
change change it to deep numpy if you
would like to and is almost fully
compatible there are a few things we're
still working on no surprises in here
and
no conversion nothing is required to do
here questions no good so the next thing
we did was auto glue one so Auto glue
one is an auto ml toolkit that we're
actively developing we released its it
is now parts of it is GA and is again
it's Apache 2.0 so what we have in here
has got different segments in it so what
auto glue one does first is trying to do
the features that we have is trying to
do hyper parameter optimization or and
architecture search through different
mechanisms so what other cool one does
in here the first thing that you have
you can have a certain number of tiles
basically they're basic tasks so we're
adding more tasks here we are saying
that we were doing to do an image
classification so you can also do object
detection you can also do tabular
prediction in tabular prediction is when
you have a table and you want to
basically predict one or two or three
columns multiple columns from a
basically tabular data what we're having
here is that from auto gluon we're using
image classification as tasks and then
we set a data set to it and when we say
task fit when we say fit what it does
for us is going to basically train the
model based on the default values that
we have is going to have multiple
basically training in order to figure
out what's the best basically set of
hyper parameters is going to be set so
so it uses it's created basically what
it does it does multiples of strategies
you can use a strategy of using Bayesian
hyper parameter optimization I just
talks about it just quickly later on it
can use random search you can use
reinforcement learning based on the
strategy of search that's running to do
and it's going to be basically doing it
automatically based on the hyper
parameters that is in the first line in
here is completely based on default
values so that's all you need to do
after that few lines after these three
lines you have a date whatever wherever
in your dataset is you given the data
set you give it a task and then you safe
it it goes and picks up multiples of
architectures it goes much bells of
epoch number of epochs it goes and
figures or what basically decides about
a random a default set of your mini
batch size up to my optimizer basically
your optimizer it gets all of that and
then it applies high performance
optimization to that to figure out the
best result for you and train your model
and give you the best result and that's
all it takes that's these three lines of
code including the import or you can
change your default configuration in the
second bit as you see in here we were
just trying to say you know what just
don't use the random number of networks
that we're giving you use multiples and
networks but the list that we're giving
you that includes resonate 50 v1 and
resident 50 v2 we could have also given
its resident 152 we could have given it
whatever there are more than 50
different algorithms that it can
actually identify it in here for a sorry
for image classification duress than 50
but there's I don't know
twenty-something algorithm that you
could actually give a list of so you
don't want to go too crazy
because then it's going to take a lot of
time and money to do that but you can
actually identify a list in here what
would you do that since you're using
transfer learning in here so you want to
use the models that have most basically
the best similarities what you want to
do that Japan example that I gave you
that from two days to under an hour for
training one of the things that we did
instead of using ResNet 152 which is
2050 because they were doing a very
simple classification in there so they
didn't really need to have this very
huge network in there there are other
things as well in there oh by the way to
tell you how much the optimization can
be actually important that again that
Japan case the customers I was trying to
do that the projected saving on training
per year was about 22 million dollars so
these are non-trivial numbers when you
do proper optimization is worth spending
time on it so you can also give it
basically the the next line another
basically thing I will do is basically
we learn
a jeweler so we're just are you there
are two different strategies there's a
polynomial and a cosine learning rate
scheduler any question about what
learning or scheduler is and what we're
using for question question no good you
can have also got a question section at
the end okay so and the number of epochs
we say four so it creates jobs basically
off to four epochs is trying to choose
so what new search algorithm we have in
here one is a Bayesian optimization so
what is a Bayesian optimization I can
give you a simple that so a Bayesian
optimization is using an acquisition
function and the way it does try to
imagine you are going to so I give you a
different basically probably
distribution versus expectations so
that's quite important here so a
probability distribution can be very
expensive if you have a huge space or
you don't know how many items you have
but let's try with a smaller space I
give you a box inside your box you have
ten green balls and then you have ten
red nosed right so then you want to see
the prediction what is the probability
of things that you're trying to take out
of that box you empty the box you count
them all and say there are five of this
and there's five of this I put it back
and then you say I know that the
probability of taking the red ball here
is about 50 percent right and then you
take one and then it's after you take
one you know red is out the next one is
forty nine to be red or five in nine to
be to be green so and so on and so forth
but what if you have about 200 million
volts in there and there are multiples
of colors and then it no longer cheap to
go and just turn it upside down and it
starts taking a look at it or it could
be worse because it also could be from
basically there is nothing in there but
there is a little bit of a you know like
gun and just keeps inserting bowls of
certain color based on a certain formula
well so you don't even know even if you
have all the time and the money in the
world to make it opposite darling
say you just can't simply no because not
every rule is in there it's just being
just added to it as you go through so
that comes the notion of expectation so
the notion of expectation is coming from
sampling and expecting what your
probability distribution possibly is so
the way it works so I give you a ball I
give you a box and winning it they're a
bunch of all right cell leaders one
suppose in there I cannot tell you what
color I cannot tell you what
distribution I cannot tell you anything
just go figure out what it is so this is
called the black box right so the black
box system the only thing that you have
you can take balls out of it so I took a
red oh I took a green oh there's a blue
in it so as you go through and then you
start making an understanding of the
world inside that box so that's called
and that's the notion of expectation the
way it works so I take a red one sample
just oh I have a red I would say my next
Bowl is definitely gonna be red not
definitely I expect that it to have a
high probability of like probability of
one to be red and I take oh it's it's a
blue so I have a I have done two
sampling I haven't read and I have a
blue oh I expect that my next one to be
50/50 either red or blue and I go and
come back on with the red now it changes
the game to probability so every sample
I do I put in a data set in the back and
whatever observed here it's forms my
opinion about the world I'm trying to
look at it so I have no idea what's in
it but I have an expectation after I do
a thousand sampling I have a pretty good
idea about what the probability of the
next thing is going to be so this is
Gaussian process in a nutshell so when
you're trying to do you're trying to do
a little bit of a sampling from the
sampling that you do you're trying to
figure out what the basically future is
going to look look inside that box so
for that you need everything is about an
acquisition function what is an
acquisition function in this case was me
going there sampling physically taking
that thing out now let's try to have a
much better example of that so the
example is you move to Tokyo tomorrow
and then you want to drive to your
office and as you want to draw if your
office you are going to figure out
what's the expectation of how long it
takes to go to work so first you have
absolutely no idea yeah I've never been
to Tokyo you don't know how the traffic
works nothing no I think it's all you
live in the suburb and your office in
the center of the city so you say I
think it takes 200 hours to get to work
this random number you start four and
then you go and here and there you
basically stop and take basically
measure of time so so you need an
acquisition function that tell you at
what points do you actually want to
measure your time so probably you don't
want to do it all the time on the
motorway on the motorway see I'll just
do it when I start and I do it again
when I get out of motorway and then I do
it every three streets blocks so first
in the outer rims of the city then you
have basically larger street blocks and
they're not as busy and then you get so
you have to have a smart function to
tell you how frequently you sample in
order to get the best results because if
you sample too much it's also very
expensive so what you're trying to do in
here you want to have an acquisition
function that tells you where to sample
and that acquisition function here is
just telling us where to sample the way
to sample it wants to give us either
maximum yield when you have very little
uncertainty or you know you want to
sampled in places that yield might be
small but you have a huge amount of
uncertainty that it's got called
balancing between exploration and
exploitation
so give you another example of that now
you have gone Tokyo you have gone to
your home you have gone to the office
you're going back and now you want to go
and eat you go in a restaurant that is
near your house and go and you like the
food and then do it again tomorrow do it
again tomorrow do it again tomorrow
do it again the day after and the day
after and the day after and so on until
they get absolutely sick of it so the
reason is you know that it's a greedy
selection so your acquisition function
is doing a greedy acquisition here so
what it does is say I know there is a
huge yield in here I have been in that
restaurant before there is very little
uncertainty about it but then since
you're getting sick of it otherwise you
end up eating in the same restaurant
every day over and over and
again so he said why don't know let's go
a little bit around and try another
restaurant
it might being really bad so I never
again go near it or it might be really
excellent so I might actually achieve
something in here so that's called
exploitation so you want to balance
between exploration exploitation so the
more uncertainty you have the more you
might end up finding things that are
brilliant and you had no idea about them
and the more you have try things you
want to balance between picking the good
stuff that you have already have an
experience with so that's what the
acquisition function is trying to do is
do for us in here so here we are getting
the maximum uncertainty here we're
getting low uncertainty about a good
yield so that's all about basically
balancing between the two between
exploration and exploitation so that's a
Gaussian process so what you do you
basically tells you sample here sample
here sample here so the acquisition
function gives you the future samples
you do a few samples and from those few
samples you build an expectation of
where you're the direction of your hyper
parameters or the basically that the
choice of your architecture should go
so that's Gaussian five minutes so I
extensively talked about what goes in
here so the other thing we've done is
reinforcement learning reinforcement
learning is used in here it learns and
it wants to basically maximize the
reward of the architecture or your hyper
parameter that you're trying to use so
reinforcement learning is different than
supervised learning and unsupervised
learning is a different form of learning
or Infernus reinforcement learning is
based on feedback from the environments
you've got an agent and your agents
interacts with the environment and gets
rewards for it alright let's let's see
how it could potentially work so if you
are playing chess then every move you
get a reward of minus one so that means
for just wasting time you get punished
if you
want to finish her basically game as
quickly as possible and then at the end
when you win you get a thousand so the
whole idea is you want to again build
that expectation how do I move in
relationship with my environment I make
one move environment threw something
back at me and I can move based on a
series of policies that in chess would
be the basically the move that are
allowed so what you want to do how do I
move in order to maximize my reward and
get to the final goal so this is a
reward based system this is a system
when you can actually your agent can
interact with the environment and based
on the feedback from the environment it
can decide what action to do once again
there is an exploration exploitation
here involved once again there is
basically building them an expectation
involved depending on how you're doing
are a lot are getting to the details of
reinforcement learning what else do we
do we do nos so Nass is that we want to
find an architecture that maximizes the
reward with the corresponding network
that minimizes the training loss so you
want to do an optimization of minimizing
loss well you saw that optimization
problem through maximizing rewards and
one of things we have done in here is
using reinforcement learning to solve
that problem so there are two ways of
doing that one is nice so you have a
popular basic architecture space like
starting from the mobile in that series
and then you basically construct an RL
reinforcement learning that does search
and figures out what the best solution
is apart from NASA is very expensive
because what it does it does a lot of
sampling and when it does a lot of
sampling and then it has to build these
convolutional neural networks frame this
and that so that's very very expensive
we have also introduced something I
haven't put in here it's quite recent
called eNOS so eNOS is trying to do a
different approach to that by weight
sharing so that means creating a super
net and that super net is an oversized
net and it shares shares the weights and
then it doesn't sound polish at each
iteration it
as a bunch of stuff examples at the end
of measures at the end of so it's going
to be a lot less expensive what else
we're trying to do in the future
releases we're going to have text class
text classification so that's the
transformer and birth if you know these
architectures these are both from
basically Google translation teams so
there is on tabular data we're going to
have more implementations we're going to
implement Yolo SSD and faster or CNN
hopefully soon so we're going to
basically have a newer version of Nass
we're going to include glue on CV and
glue on NLP integration so you gain
access to every possible basic
architecture that is implemented in
there and more and more applications are
including pose estimation that is
already being included in glue on CV to
be added here so you can create
basically outer ml post pose estimation
these are references if you want to take
a picture of them they're supposed to be
useful so deep nonpoint documentation
also gluon documentation including the
ooh that outs a gluon probably that
wouldn't work I hope it does I hope it's
not internal but now you can also just
search auto glue on and now there is a
basically a part of MX that IO and
github you can find it so you can find a
more about glue on itself about how to
develop neural networks using glue on
crash course the book I mentioned is
darf to deep learning also if you teach
places we put university courses that we
teach we included in the same thing so
Alex and mu have put their Stanford
course in there and I had done something
in Hong Kong University of Science
Technology so I have to add my material
and there's actually it's ready to go
training material the NLP CV and the TS
toolkits for different use cases so
before I get literally kicked out of
here I better stop now if you have any
questions feel free yeah we have time
for one question
yeah question here thanks thanks very
much for the talk
could you say something quickly about
how deep numpy is implemented like what
language you wrote it in what platforms
it's available on will it just be
available on Amazon infrastructure it's
an open source and you can use it under
MX nets so you can also import it in
different platforms so I think there is
a PI torch example of that I haven't
used it with Peters personally I think
there's a Python example that tells the
PI Church people also also gluon works
with PI tours so the deep numpy as you
say when you basically it it it's it
installs with MX nets and then you can
simply import it and just use the coding
for torch I'm not quite sure how to use
it how straightforward it is but you
definitely can't use it with MX no Thank
You Luhan ok thanks so much series for a
great talk I'm gonna be here somewhere
around for dinner I've got a flight
about five o'clock got to pick up my
suitcase from hotel so couple hours
probably I can stick around yeah cool so
if you wanted to get more info from
Cyrus from probably different fields as
well you can talk to him catch me on
there perfect great country oh yeah all
right great
yes there's no it
[Applause]